et une face à la percée des talibans les
etats-unis se voient contraints de
revoir leurs plans washington a décidé
d'envoyer et 3000 soldats dans le pays
pour permettre à l'évacuation des
ressortissants américains on vient tout
de suite notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnin
thomas bonsoir la maison blanche affirme
qu'il ne s'agit pas là d'un réengagement
militaires
n'ont pas de ré engagement militaire
mais force est de constater que 3000
soldats vont être de nouveau envoyé à
destination de l'afghanistan plus
précisément à l'aéroport de kaboul ils
vont rejoindre les 650 soldats
américains qui sont déjà sur place il
faut noter aussi que 3500 soldats
américains supplémentaires vont eux être
déployée au koweït pour être prêts à
être envoyés en cas de besoin en renfort
justement en afghanistan écoutez les
précisions de ce dispositif militaire
c'est le porte parole du pentagone qui
prend la parole
le premier mouvement sera constitué de
trois bataillons d'infanterie qui se
trouve actuellement dans la zone de
responsabilité du commandement central
des états unis ils se rendront à
l'aéroport international de kaboul dans
les 24 à 48 heures deux des ses
bataillons relève des marines et le
troisième de l'armée américaine
il reste donc une question est ce que le
retrait complet des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan pourra être effectuée
d'ici le 31 août comme initialement
prévu par le président américain envers
la question a été posée justement au
porte parole du pentagone qui n'a pas
vraiment plu répondrai pas vraiment pu
fixer d'agenda précis pour le retrait
total des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan et la x aussi expliqué que
la chute de kaboul elle n'était pas
inéluctable en rappelant que les forces
armées afghanes étaient plus nombreuses
que les talibans mais il faut bien
comprendre que l'optimisme affiché ces
dernières semaines par les autorités
américaines a été douché par la percée
des talibans en afghanistan ces
dernières semaines avec kaboul donc qui
pourraient tomber aux mains des talibans
bien plus vite que prévu et c'est pour
cette raison que l'évacuation a été
accélérée en afghanistan en tout cas
cette situation attire les critiques de
la part de l'opposition l'a notamment vu
un communiqué de donald trump ou encore
des figures républicaines prendre la
parole pour
et bien critiqué la décision de joe
biden écouter ils auraient dû incombait
au gouvernement américain de procéder à
une sortie responsable lors du retrait
des forces restant d'afghanistan dans
quelques mois l'administration maiden a
mené un processus de retrait bâclé qui a
maintenant livrer un pays entier aux
terroristes
alors certains ici font aussi la
comparaison entre ces scènes
d'évacuation auquel on va assister
vraisemblablement en afghanistan avec
elle et celle qu'on a pu voir à l'époque
lors de la guerre du vietnam à saigon
lorsque des employés de l'ambassade
américaine avait dû être évacué par
hélicoptère depuis le toit de cette
ambassade alors c'est une comparaison
qui avait été rejetée il y à un mois par
joe biden qui avait affirmé que les deux
situations on n'avait rien à voir mais
il ya quand même toujours des éléments
de comparaison avec cette défaite qui
était finalement assez couru d'avancé le
washington post rappelle dans un
éditorial publié ce vendredi que des
documents qui ont été dévoilées en 2019
par le quotidien américain montrer que
les autorités américaines savaient
qu'elles ne pourraient pas éradiqué de
manière durable la menace des taliban et
ces documents il avait été cachée
pendant longtemps au grand public ici
aux etats unis il faut aussi noter que
les à la presse se montre très critique
contre joe biden contre ce qu'elle
qualifie globalement de la première
grosse erreur diplomatique du président
américain lui qui voulait envoyer un
message fort à l'occasion des 20 ans du
11-septembre et bien finalement il y
aura un symbole inverse avec cette
défaite américaine contre les insurgés
en afghanistan qui pourrait en quelque
sorte galvanisé d'autres mouvements
islamistes dans le monde et on pourrait
craindre aussi en afghanistan un
scénario similaire à celui là ce qui
s'était déroulé en irak en 2011 lorsque
les troupes américaines s'étaient
retirés et qu'elle avait dû se
redéployer quelques années plus tard
face à l'émergence de l'état islamique
merci beaucoup thomas bonnet en direct
de washington